servos s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem ganz besonderen video ich habe mir
hier für die kamera von meinem
mitbewohner ausgeliehen der hat eine aus
700 die habe ich mir gerade geklaute
ersten mal für mich mit der
spiegelreflex ist gefragt die schultern
und heute habe ich das ganz besonders
für euch wie gesagt wir werden heute ein
letztes team respekt dafür befinden wir
uns hier auf meinem lieblings server
wohnung hd nat als allererstes müssen
uns in diese leute hier begeben
die lobbys dunkel
wir sehen ist und da unten ist schon
unser ziel unsere destination ich bin
heute letzt schlafmodus brett wars
diesen zweck hier unten kommen wo die
decke weg 20 decken kills es ist einfach
nicht leicht leute ganz ehrlich ist
einfach nicht leicht aber irgendwie
schaffe ich doch immer wieder diese
runden etwas zu gewinnen und damit ist
auch dieses letzte schlaf für heute
schon vorbei ich hoffe dadurch gefallen
wie immer wenn es der fall ist last zwei
daumen da von beide hand einen einfach
abschneiden und da lassen könnt ihr mir
all meine